bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout l'été je vous
propose de voir ou de revoir les temps
forts de la dernière session
parlementaire retour aujourd'hui aux
travaux de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur le coût économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air une
commission d'enquête présidée par le
sénateur les républicains jean-franç fr
hon et qui avait pour rapporteur leilla
Aichi sénatrice écologiste cette
commission d'enquête avait chiffré à 100
milliards d'euros par an le coût annuel
de cette pollution de l'air pour la
France dans le cadre de ses travaux elle
avait auditionné la ministre de
l'écologie c'est Golen royale et vous
allez le voir à l'époque les échanges
avaient été plutôt musclés avec la
rapporteur de cette commission d'enquête
leil ai cette dernière en effet
attaquait le gouvernement estimait qu'il
n'y avait pas d'effort for suffisant
fait pour réduire la place du diesel en
France tout de suite donc retour à cette
audition Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs je vous remercie de vous être
engagé sur cette commission d'enquête
relative au coût économique et financier
de la pollution de l'air parce que c'est
un sujet de santé publique majeur c'est
aussi un enjeu social car ce sont les
populations les plus fragiles qui sont
exposés à une mauvaise qualité de l'air
les coûts sanitaires de la pollution
sont estimés entre 20 et 30 milliards
d'euros par an selon une étude de 2012
publiée par mon ministère au
Commissariat général du développement
durable ces coûts sont essentiellement
lié à la
mortalité il faut y ajouter le coût du à
l'inconfort à l'inquiétude à la
souffrance du fait d'être malade sur ces
20 à 30 milliards 1 à 2 milliards
pourrait être directement économisé
chaque année pour le système de soins
par des mesures simples plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'habitants en
France sont exposés à une mauvaise
qualité de l'air dans certaines zones du
territoire et particul ulièrement dans
les zones urbaines à forte
densité la France vient de recevoir un
avis motivé de la Commission européenne
pour non respect des valeurs sanitaires
pour les particules PM10 10 zones sont
visées Marseille toulonb Paris doubéun
valencienne Grenoble Lyon Nice la
Martinique et quelques zones urbaines en
régions ronalpe et PACA nous allons très
prochainement répondre à cet avis motivé
en faisant état des actions engagé des
résultats obtenus qui conduisent déjà à
considérer que le nombre de zones en
dépassement s'est probablement réduit je
vais revenir dans quelques instants des
nouvelles actions engagées et bien
évidemment je pense que les travaux de
votre commission d'enquête qui
s'inscrive dans cette actualité brûlante
de la demande de la Commission
européenne pourrait fort utilement aussi
être transmis comme élément d'appui aux
politiques gouvernementales qui
tiendrait compte de vos recommandations
que le gouvernement pourrait reprendre à
son compte et communiquer euh en
complément à la Commission européenne
c'est dire l'importance de de vos
audition et euh de vos propositions
auxquelles je serai particulièrement
vigilante parce que je le répète cela
pourra nous aider à répondre à cette
avis motivé de la Commission
européenne des dépassements de valeur
sanitaire pour le dioxyde d'azote
concernent également une quinzaine de
territoire en France la Commission a
engagé le 13 février 2014 une une
procédure Union européenne pilote la
Commission a clôturé la procédure et la
France vient de recevoir la mise en
demeure pour 19 zones là aussi les
actions engagées doivent être
communiquées à la
Commission dans ce contexte la
participation de tous les acteurs est
indispensable d'abord pour réduire de
manière pérenne les concentrations de
polluants dans l'atmosphère en agissant
sur le transport sur l'industrie sur
l'agriculture sur les
constructions pour éviter les pics et le
dépassement récurrent prend des seuils
réglementaires notamment lorsque les
conditions météorologiques les
favorisent troisièmement pour informer
les Français des risques et des sources
de pollution et protéger leur santé et
les inciter aussi à agir chaque fois
qu'ils le peuvent le bilan national de
la qualité de l'air qui sera publié par
le ministère en septembre montrera qu'en
2014 la situation s'est améliorée ce qui
est la preuve que l'action collective
est payante pour les particules PM10
seul une agglomération de plus de 250000
à habitant a dépasser les seuils
réglementaires contre 5 en
2013 pour le dioxyde d'azote 13
agglomérations de plus de 250000
habitants n'ont pas respecté le seuil de
concentration contre 15 en 2013 petite
amélioration passe de 13 à 15 mais il
reste donc beaucoup à entreprendre et
j'ai engagé pour ma part des actions qui
ont été remises en perspective devant le
Conseil national de l'air du 2 juin
dernier et donc on appuie bien sûr sous
toutes les propositions des forces vives
et des action notamment qui sont prises
par les élus locaux puisque c'est
essentiellement dans les agglomérations
queon a besoin que les forces vives des
agglomérations prennent leur
responsabilité premièrement la création
du certificat qualité de l'air sur
lequel je m'étais engagé devant la
conférence environnementale a été mise
au point il va être expérimenté va
donner des avantages aux véhicules les
moins polluants cette classification va
s'appuyer sur les émissions polluant des
voitures particulières des deux roues
des poids lourds des autobus et
comportera cette classe en fonction de
la motorisation et de l'âge du véhicule
une classe spécifique est réservée au
véhicule électriquees zéro émission une
dérogation sera accordé au véhicules
d'intervention et d'urgence cette
échelle de classement va permettre aux
collectivités notamment au Mair des
grandes agglomérations président
d'agglomération de moduler finement les
mesures incitatives ou restrictives que
ces collectivités souhaitent mettre en
place en concertation avec les habitants
et les acteurs économiques du territoire
elles pourront par exemple et je fais
référence à la loi de transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
créer des zones à circulation restreinte
qui sont prévu dans la loi dans la
partie euh transport propre que les
sénateurs et sénatrices ici présents
connaissent bien pourrai avoir
abondamment participé ces zones à
circulation restreintte pour la qualité
de l'air seront réservé à certaines
classes de véhicules toute l'année ou
certains jours de la semaine pour
diminuer drastiquement la
pollution deuxièmement proposer certains
avantages de stationnement de voies de
circulation seever VH électriqu au
véhicules plus faiblement émetteurs pour
encourager l'usage je souhaite que ce
dispositif soit simple et lisible pour
les usagers comme pour les agents
chargés du contrôle et limite les
risques de fraude afin de rendre
efficaces les mesures qui seront mises
en place à l'appui de cette
identification donc ce certificat a été
élaboré bien évidemment avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur puisque bien évidemment
pour les contrôles il faut que les les
certificats soient lisibles il sera
délivré par voie postale à titre
individuel à chaque propriétaire de
véhiculle qui en fera la demande sur
Internet il est mis en place au 1er
janvier 2016 des expérimentations seront
lancées dès l'automne le coût du
certificat sera au maximum de 5 € bref
c'est une démarche à la fois pédagogique
nullement porteuse d'exclusion euh
puisque euh les entreprises pourront
être amenées à s'interroger sur l'offre
de mobilité qu'elles peuvent proposer à
leurs salariés les usagers seront
responsabilisés sur leur contribution à
la qualité de l'
les élus disposeront d'un nouveau moyen
d'action les constructeurs automobiles
et les industriels seront incités à
innover et à mettre sur le marché des
transports propres les pouvoirs publics
pourront adapter les mesures d'urgence
en cas de pic de pollution en
interdisant la circulation au véhicules
les plus polluants et pas seulement avec
un système per impè qui n'a aucun sens
en terme de de mesure de la pollution
même si ça réduit simplement en
volume la circulation mais ça ne cible
pas sur les véhicules les plus polluants
alors j'ai entendu effectivement un
certain nombre de réactions notamment de
la part des foyers qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se s'acheter une voiture moins
polluante je précise donc le
gouvernement a mis en place une prime de
10000 € cette année pour inciter à
l'achat de véhiculle électrique a étendu
cette prime aussi au véhicules propres
d'occasion ce qui était une forte
demande don la prime bien sûr
inférieur et l'idée c'est d'inciter
aussi les constructeurs à mettre sur le
marché des véhicules avec des ventes
mensualisées pour permettre aussi à
toutes les tous les toutes les les
niveaux de de revenu à y accéder
j'ajoute aussi que ne voulant pas
d'écologie
punitive ce certificat est facultatif on
dit pourquoi facultatif faudrait que ça
soit obligatoire et cetera il est
facultatif parce que du coup seul les
voitures propres vont demander le
certificat donc vous bénéficiez des
avantages et la stigmatisation qui était
crainte effectivement par les
certificats sur les voitures les plus
polluantes à la limite il a pas besoin
d'exister puceque les gens qui ont des
voitures très polluantes ont pas intérêt
à mettre le certificat sur leur
pare-brise en revanche ils ne pourront
pas bénéficier des avantages liés au
véhicules propres donc on est dans un
dans un dans une dynamique euh positive
euh qui permet effectivement de ne pas
stigmatiser c'était une petite crainte
que j'ai vu surgir sur Internet o les
gens qui avaient des voitures polluantes
disent mais nous on on va pas pouvoir se
rouler avec un certificat qui va nous
stigmatiser de couleur sombre parce que
pour l'instant on n pas les moyens de
changer de voiture donc voilà voyez il
faut prendre en considération tous ces
aspects pour que vraiment on s'inscrive
dans des dynamiques positives et que ce
soit surtout les constructeurs qui
s'engagent les entreprises qui fassent
vraiment des plans de mobilité comme
c'est prévu dans la loi de transition
énergétique les collectivités
territoriales qui développent des
transports propres ou les transports de
substitution propre quand euh il y a des
pics de pollution euh et c'est cette
dynamique là là qu'en second lieu donc
les certificats ensuite j'ai lancé
l'appel à projet ville respirable en 5
ans pour mobiliser les collectivités et
tester des solutions innovantes le
cahier des charges a été rendu public
les collectivités effectivement
agglomération joue un rôle essentiel
dans la lutte contre la pollution de
l'air elles ont des compétences pour
agir concrètement cette appel à projet
va permettre d'expérimenter des mesures
radicales pour la qualité de l'air afin
de de faire baisser sensiblement la
pollution ils vont bénéficier d'une aide
financière pouvant aller jusqu'à 1
million d'euros par laureéa pour
déployer localement les dispositifs du
projet de loi de transition énergétique
et notamment définir rapidement des
zones à circulation restreines engager
rapidement le renouvellement des flottes
publiques des autobus et des taxis parce
que les gens ne comprennent pas pourquoi
on leur demande de rouler propre
lorsqu'ils voit des bus ou des taxis
polluants ensuite mettre en place les
primes de conversion y compris pour les
deux roues et les utilitaires développer
la mobilité électrique avec le
déploiement notamment des bornes de
recharge de façon accélérée inciter
toutes les entreprises à avoir des plans
de
circulation multiplier les incitations
au covoiturage et enfin engager les
déplacements en deux
roues mettre en place ensuite avec les
professionnels concernés des mesures de
lutte contre la pollution dans les
transports publics le ministère a engagé
des discussions avec les compagnies de
d'autobus pour mettre en place des plans
d'élimination des diesels les plus
polluants dans l'industrie nous avons
lancé des audits et des programmes
d'action notamment dans les PME ensuite
dans l'activité agricole qui est une
source de pollution importante qui est
tou mais je pense qu'il faut avoir le
courage de le dire parce que c'est aussi
l'intérêt des agriculteurs qu'on puisse
identifier ces sources de pollution les
nommer et euh c'est aussi une question
de leur propre santé qui est en jeu et
je crois que les choses commencent à
évoluer de façon très positive il y a le
problème des produits des pendages qui
dispersent des polluants dans l'air et
donc là aussi il est parfaitement
possible de de même que j'ai interdit
vous le savez les les épandages aériens
je pense que les pulvérisations qui ont
lorsqu'on observait les pics de
pollution à Paris jou un rôle très
important dans le pic de les pics de
pollution et notamment malheureusement
les épendages aérien du centre de
l'Europe il y a pas de frontière he pour
la pollution qui ont été rabattu sur le
nord de la France est sur l'Est euh il
faut donc engager des techniques qui
arrêtent déjà en France et puis
peut-être mener la bataille au niveau
européen pour arrêter les les les
épendages par pulvérisation qui contribu
gravement à la pollution de
l'air dans la construction la rénovation
thermique des logements les
constructions énergie positive les
filtres à particules pour le chauffage
au bois euh le remplacement de des
appareils de chauffage anciens sont
également en mouvement et dans les
appels à projet sur les villes
respirables fara que ces villes mettent
en place des actions d'information des
citoyens puisqu'on est à la fois dans
l'application de la loi de transition
énergétique pour la performance
énergétique des bâtiments la mise en
place du crédit d'impôt sur la
transition énergétique qui permet à tous
les particuliers de changer leurs
appareils de chauffage ancien polluant
en appareil de chauffage plus performant
y compris pour le chauffage au bois et
puis les bâtiments énergie positive sont
des bâtiments justement où il y a plus
de de pollution
atmosphérique les projets donc ces
projet de ville respirable en 5 ans et T
toutes ces actions ne sont pas réservées
au lauréat du de l'appel à projet ville
respirable bien évidemment l'idée c'est
de montrer comment on peut concentrer et
accélérer avec une impulsion plus forte
la mutation de la la civilisation
urbaine
finalement seront réservé aux
agglomérations situées dans l'une des 36
six zones couvertes par un plan de
protection de l'atmosphère approuvé ou
en projet la date limite de dépôt des
dossiers fixée au 5 septembre pour une
annonce des laoréa le 25 septembre lors
de la Journée nationale de la qualité de
l'air ça paraît long mais en fait c'est
très court parce que ça veut dire que
sur tous les aspects des sources de
pollution il va falloir apporter des
projets structurés qui souvent sont déjà
en gestation mais ça ça va permettre de
les accélérer les lauréas bénéficieront
d'un appui financier méthodologique les
aides de laadem le financement de du
fond de la transition énergétique et le
programme des investissements d'avenir
pour les actions agricoles les
financements du ministère seront
mobilisés notamment le plan ecofito qui
bénéficie là aussi de fonds importants
qui pourront être concentrés sur les
projets
intégrés en troisème lieu donc les
certificats les les l'appel à projet
ville respirable en 5 ans troisièmement
les aides financières en faveur de la
qualité de
l'air comme cela a été annoncé par le
gouvernement lors de la conférence
environnementale il faut
rééquilibrer progressivement la
fiscalité
entre les différentes sources de
d'essence enfin entre le diesel et
l'essence pour être clair en prenant en
compte les impacts écologiques pour les
entreprises et les citoyens donc le
bonus automobile et le nouveau bonus
porte des leurs fruits pour aider à
diffuser les véhicules propres au prier
trimestre de l'année
2015 je parle du bonus de 10000 € on
constate une progression de 89 % en un
an des ventes de véhicules électriques
enfin on par de bas donc 89 on se fait
plaisir ça fait beaucoup mais quand même
il y a pas raison de ne pas le dire 2903
voitures particulières exactement
électrique ont été immatriculé au prier
trimestre contre 1500 le estre précédent
ah oui il faut bien commencer bon
euh
donc selon les constructeurs les
commandes de véhicules électriques qui
sont déjà en forte hausse en avril avec
des volumes 4 à 8 fois supérieurs à ce
constater en avril
2014 les derniers chiffres connus de
vente en mai confirment la tendance mais
bien évidemment on sait très bien ce
qu'il farait pour déclencher ses achats
c'est le déploiement des bornes
électriques qui est également en cours
puisque dans un programme
d'investissement d'avenir il y a le
déploiement des bornes électriques d'un
côté et d'autre part bien évidemment
c'est l'autonomie l'autonomie qui qui
reste encore la le point d'interrogation
et en même temps on observe que quand
des entreprises ou des particuliers ont
fait le choix de véhicules électriques
ils peuvent pas revenir en arrière
tellement le le le le le progrès
qualitatif et financier est considérable
et donc une des solutions sans doute
serait de déployer des flottes
électriques dans les entreprises avec
des système des LO de location salarié
il y a aussi le covoiturage je pense de
de véhicules électriques qui pourrait
être quand même intéressant et le
déploiement des deux roues électriques
le Parlement je le rappelle d'ailleurs a
souhaité inscrire dans la loi relative à
la transition énergétique plusieurs
disposition pour encourager les salariés
à utiliser leurs vélos l'indemnité
kilométrique vélo la déduction d'impôts
pour les sociétés qui mettent à
disposition de leurs salariés des
flottes de
bicyclette dans le secteur des
transports c'est mesures viendront en
complément de l'engagement de l'État et
des collectivités locales à qui la loi
pour la transition énergétique demandera
de renouveler des véhicules propres par
leur flotte de véhicules dont celle de
bus et de car je précise aussi que dans
la loi de transition énergétique les
collectivités locales doivent
obligatoirement lorsqu'il remplace des
véhicules des flottes administratives
obligatoirement acheter un véhicule sur
deux qui est un véhicule propre ou
électrique quatrièmement il faut
vraiment mobiliser la profession
agricole sur la qualité de l'air d'abord
parce que je le rappelle c'est pas les
agriculteurs qui qui polluent les autres
c'est les activités agricoles qui
subissent aussi eux elles-mêmes les
dégâts causés par la pollution de l'air
les rendements agricoles peuvent
notamment être impactés par les épisodes
de pollution les baisses de rendement
peuvent aller jusqu'à 20 % sur le blé
pendant les périodes de fortte
concentration en ozone mais certaines
pratiques agricoles contribue également
au pollution de l'atmosphère je l'ai dit
la diminution des émissions de polluant
agricole est indispensable elle rejoint
d'ailleurs la problématique de de
relance des polinisateurs et de lutte
contre la mortalité des abeilles et des
pollinisateurs qui est aussi un fléo
pour
l'agriculture et notamment sur les
épisodes de pollution printaniier qui
est vraiment un sujet à prendre en
considération en tant que tel d'ailleurs
vous avez vu que les les pics de
pollution dont on a parlé récemment ce
sont les pollutions au printemps parce
que là on a toute la concentration on a
à la fois une augmentation de la
température de l'air donc la pollution
automobile qui s'accentue et on a bien
sûr les épendages agricoles qui viennent
renforcer la pollution de l'air euh par
les transports et donc il y a une forte
contribution de l'ammoniaque dans la
formation des particules au même titre
que les émissions liées au trafic des
nouveaux financements sont mis en place
pour expérimenter avec le soutien du
ministère de l'Agriculture et de l'ADEM
des pratiques plus performantes une
enveloppe de 20 millions d'euros sur 5
ans est dédiée à ce programme il a donc
les moyens financiers il faut maintenant
les cibler et les orienter vers des
actions
efficaces une table ronde avec la
profession agricole sur la qualité de
l'air est en cours d'organisation pour
examiner quelle solution s'offre aux
exploitants à l'approche de la période
d'hiver aussi plus propice aux épisodes
de pollution donc il y a le pic de
printemps et ensuite il y a le pic de
d'entrée dans
l'hiver 5èmement je souhaite améliorer
le dispositif de gestion des épisodes de
pollution et vous souvenez toutes les
les polémiques au mois de mars dernier
et donc j'ai mandaté avec les ministres
en charge de l'Intérieur et de la santé
une mission d'inspection sur la gestion
des épisodes de pollution pour disposer
des recommandations pour faire face aux
prochaines crises cette mission a
présenté ses réflexions devant le
Conseil national de l'air début juin et
va rendre son rapport très prochainement
6ièmement je souhaite développer la
surveillance des polluant non
réglementés pour avoir une approche
dynamique une campagne nationale
exploratoire de surveillance des
pesticides a été lancé comme décidé dans
le cadre de la feuille de route de la
dernière conférence environnementale
elle va s'appuyer sur les
recommandations de lanes sur le
protocole harmonisé de surveillance qui
a été établi par le laboratoire central
de surveillance de la qualité de l'air
et mise en œuvre par les associations
agréées de surveillance de la qualité de
l'air l'an est en cours de saisine aussi
pour les autres polluant non réglementés
car il convient d'être vigilant dans les
années qui viennent une journée
nationale de la qualité de l'air est
prévue le 25 septembre là aussi pour
mobiliser tous les Français donc ce sera
intéressant qu'à ce moment là on puisse
déployer les actions et les
recommandations qui seront les vôtres
enfin il y a toutes les actions aussi de
mesures de de la qualité de l'air dans
les les établissements qui reçoivent du
public vous saz en particulier dans les
écoles moi j'avais été saisie par les
maires pour essayer de d'être plus
pragmatique sur la question de de la
mesure dans chaque de chaque crèche de
chaque école maternelle de chaque
collège et de chaque salle de de lycée
je m'en suis rendu compte en tant que
présidente de région par quand j'ai vu
inscrit le budget pour le calcul le
contrôle de la qualité de l'air je dit
mais comment est-ce que les
collectivités vont payer une charge donc
j'ai j'ai j'ai assoupli le texte
réglementaire et j'ai fait mettre au
point par le quel organisme qui a mis au
point le un kit linéris qui a mis au
point un kit de mesure de l'air ce qui
fait que les employés municipaux euh
peuvent procéder eux-mêmes aux mesures
de qualité de l'air dans leurs
équipements municipaux les départements
dans les collèges les régions dans les
lycées sans avoir recours à des des
cabinets privé très très coûteux en
revanche s'ils veulent un
approfondissement d' d'un d'une
indication donnée par des kits
d'autocontrôle de la qualité de l'air
bien évidemment ils peuvent procéder à
des analyses complémentaires voilà il y
aura encore certainement beaucoup de
choses à dire mais j'imagine que vous
avez des questions tels sont les
éléments monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que je tenez à porter à votre
connaissance en étant bien évidemment
comme je vous dis très attentive et très
demandeuse des propositions que vous
ferez car je le répète nous sommes dans
un contentieux européen et moi je le
vois de façon positive tant mieux on a
un contentieux européen donc moi j'ai
engagé mon ministère qui souvent on est
dans des positions défensives et on
essaie de de trouver les arguments pour
compter tester la mise en demeure
européenne et bien moi je pense qu'il
faut faire tout le contraire et saisir
les occasions de ces mises en demeure
européennne et ben pour être à la
hauteur et puis pour changer de de
modèle pour faire en sorte que d'un
problème nous fassions une solution et
même un élément de de progrès et
d'anticipation merci beaucoup madame la
ministre je note avec satisfaction et
plaisir le bonheur qui est le vôtre de
connaître des contentieux pour
sortir pour sortir à la fois avec envie
et avec le sourire surtout et comme le
sourire est sur ma voisine madame la
rapporteur je ne résiste évidemment pas
plus longtemps à la joie de lui passer
la parole je nous appelle simplement à
l'issue des questions de Madame la
rapporteur à de la concision chers
collègues lorsque chacun de nous aura la
parole je vous vois déjà nombreux et
gourmands pour le questionnement
simplement nous notre notre temps comme
celui de madame la ministre est
également compté et je vais pendant que
madame la rapporteur pose les questions
je vais prendre voilà les doigts qui se
lèvent il y a aucun souci personne ne
sera
oublié madame la ministre merci de de
votre exposé je vais vous poser un
certain nombre de questions extrêmement
euh court si on pouvait également avoir
des réponses courtes et concises pour
que l'ensemble de mes collègues puisse
également poser un certain nombre de de
questions depuis 1983 et les premières
études de de l'OMS nous avons la
certitude que la pollution de l'air a un
impact sanitaire et notamment lieu le
desel ces derniers étant responsablebl
de plus de 50000 décès prématurés en
France chaque année euh de l'apparition
et de l'aggravation de nombreuses
maladies telles que des cancers du
poumon ou encore de la VCI des maladies
cardio-vasculaires des maladies
respiratoires de nombreuses allergies de
l'apparition d'irritation oculairire et
d'inflammation des muqueuses c'est
également un facteur d'accroissement des
problèmes de fertilité de risque de
malformation congénitale et de mortalité
infantile de facteurs d'affaiblissement
du système immunitaire de facteurs
d'augmentation des taux
d'hospitalisation et des études
extrêmement sérieuses démontent
désormais un lien entre la pollution de
l'air et la maladie maladie de Parkinson
voire de la maladie d'Alzheimer et très
récemment il vient d'être démontré un
lien qui entre la pollution de l'air et
l'obésité madame la ministre est-ce que
le ministère de l'écologie a réalisé des
études sur le coût économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air si
oui quel est son périmètre la durée et
le nombre de polluants qui ont fait
l'objet de de de cette de cette analyse
avez-vous également étudié les effets
cocktails madame la ministre pouvez-vous
également nous donner si vous en avez
une idée la date de l'arrêt du diesel je
me permettrai également d'observer et je
salue votre votre acharnement et la
lutte puisque vous avez précisé à mainte
reprise votre intention de lutter de
manière énergique et déterminé contre la
pollution de l'air nous sommes tous
conscients qu'il faut agir en ce sens et
pour autant vous avez supprimé l'écotaxe
vous avez réintroduit l'autorisation des
feux de cheminée et euh vous avez
parallèlement euh renié sur l'abandon
puisque vous avez abandonné la la loi de
diesel est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
qu'il y a une forme d'incohérence si je
puis dire entre le le propos affiché qui
qui qui fait qu'en fait vous vous
souhaitez aller dans le sens de la
dépollution de l'air et pour autant vous
prenez des mesures qui ne sont pas en
adéquation avec les objectifs que vous
avez voulu
fixer la semaine dernière assez
justement vous avez annoncé votre
volonté d'Inter dire la
commercialisation du roundop dans les
jardineries à titre totalement personnel
je j'adhère complètement à cette à cette
position pour autant est-ce que cette
mesure n'est pas insuffisante puisque
comme vous le savez l'impact sanitaire
des pesticides et notamment des
particulier pardon et dont l'usage des
particuliers ne représente qu'à 5 à 10 %
est-ce que ce n'est pas une mesure
infime contenue de l'impact global et je
finirai sur deux dernières
interrogations madame la ministre à part
partir de quel seuil vous considérez que
la pollution de l'air grève de manièreif
grèvant de manière
significative nos comptes publ est-ce
qu'il est pas temps de d'agir de manière
efficace est-ce que c'est un seuil à
partir de 10 milliards de 20 milliards
de 40 milliards 60 ou 100 milliards et
enfin je finirai ne croyez-vous pas que
le principe de pollueur payeur c'est
plutôt transformé aujourd'hui en
consommateur contribuable payeur je vous
remercie madame la
ministre
je je vous propose voilà bien sûr bien
sûr bien sûr madame la rapporteur oui
merci pour ces ces nombreuses questions
je pense que vous avez VO même
parfaitement décrit les dégâts
sanitaires de la pollution de de l'air
en reprenant effectivement la la liste
de toutes les atteintes à la santé sous
toutes ses formes comme je le disais
tout à l'heure en 2012 le commissariat
général au développement durable a
estimé le coût de la pollution de l'air
pour la société entre 20 et 30 milliards
d'euros par an c'est à la fois le coût
sanitaire le le coût social aussi le
coût économique et je me ferai plaisir
de vous transmettre le le détail de de
cette étude en tout cas qui rejoint tout
à fait
l'évaluation selon laquelle il a là à la
fois un enjeu de santé publique mais
aussi un enjeu économique est-ce que
excusez-moi vous interromp madame la
ministre est-ce que sur ce coût
économique de la pollution de l'air vous
avez identifié les effets cocktails
est-ce que les conséquences des effets
cocktails sont intégrés dans le calcul
que vous donnez à hauteur de 20 à 30
milliards d'euros écoutez à ce stade je
pense que que c'est intégré mais je n'ai
pas ici entre les mains le la totalité
du du rapport dans sa dans dans sa
complexité il y a à la fois euh les
impacts sur la santé liés à la pollution
de l'air c'est à la morbidité les
dépenses de traitement d'examen de
consultation médical et puis les
interactions ce que vous dites par
l'effet cocktail c'est les interactions
entre c'est ça que vous voulez dire les
les interactions entre C en fait en fait
pour préciser mon interrogation madame
le ministre nous avons eu positionné un
un certain nombre de scientifiques qui
justement précisaient nous expliquaient
en fait que sur les études qui ont été
faites les coûts sont nécessairement à
minima puisque simplement on a des
analyses sur l'impact sanitaire grosso
modo sur 6 à 20 maximum polluants et que
les effets cocktail sont absolument
jamais abordés donc si vous avez une
autre étude ceci nous intéresserait
parce que ça rentrera en contradiction
avec les différentes analyses qu'on a pu
avoir et oui je pense que je pense que
ces effets ne sont pas intégrés
dans non je ne crois pas parce que c'est
vraiment les effets mais ce qu'on peut
faire à ce moment-là suite à votre
observation c'est comme la sisine de
l'ANS est en cours on pourrait
explicitement préciser la commande
relatif aux effets cocktail parce que je
pense que nous n'y avons pas pensé voilà
voyez l'intérêt aussi de ces auditions
ça permet de d'enrichir les les travaux
et les et les
démarches ensuite sur l'écotax l'écotax
n'a pas était supprimé puisque vous le
savez que à la place du système complexe
qui je vais pas revenir sur sur ce
sujet-là mais qui entraînait quand même
une déperdition de 25 % des taxes payées
par les Français au profit d'une
rémunération d'un service rendu voilà
par des par des entreprises privées nous
avons préféré la taxe de 2 centimes sur
le gasoil qui a été appliqué donc cette
taxe a été appliquée elle a été
appliquée aussi à hauteur de 4 centimes
sur les camions euh et donc l'écotax
c'est une écotaxe donc l'écotaxe a été
au contraire simplifié avec une
rentabilité immédiate sur la question
des feux de cheminée je pense en effet
que la façon de l'interdit telle qui
généralisé telle qu'il avait été
prononcé mélanger allaigrement euh
l'interdiction des chauffages au bois
qui sont source de pollution par
particules bien évidemment surtout les
vieux chauffagees qui ne sont pas aux
normes avec euh les flambé de bois euh
de lois loisir au moment de de l'hiver
et donc h interdire à à la veille de
Noël les feux de cheminée c'est pour moi
de l'écologie punitive et c'est pour ça
que j'ai arrêté cette j'ai demandé la
réforme de cet arrêté pour bien cerner
les choses les choses sont aujourd'hui
cerné c'est-à-dire que nous avons à la
fois mis en place là aussi dans une
logique d'écologie positive le crédit
d'impôt qui va permettre au
particulierers de changer leur vieill
chaudière à bois éventuellement ante par
des chaudières à bois avec des filtres à
particules donc ça c'est très important
justement que dans les territoires les
gens soient informés de ces possibilités
de changement deuxièmement on a
encouragé la mise au point d'un système
très innovant sur des filtres à
particules qui peuvent s'installer aussi
sur les foyers ouverts parce que c'est
les flambés à foyer ouvert troisièmement
dans le crédit d'impôt les inserts
c'est-à-dire des foyers qui sont
beaucoup moins polluants sont égal
bénéficient également du crédit crédit
d'impôt et enfin je ne souhaite pas que
par une interdiction du généralisé et et
et non non adapté du chauffage au bois
on puisse porter atteinte brutalement
parce que vous connaissez l'impact des
annonces à toute la filière bois de
chauffage parce que c'était des annonces
aussi dramatiques sur la filière boî de
chauffage qui tout d'un coup se trouva
ainsi stigmatisé et comme on mélange un
peu tout quand il y a comme ça des
informations brutes de décoffrage
effectivement c'était une un mauvais
signal qui était donné puisque
parallèlement beaucoup de collectivités
développent les plateformes de
récupération le chauffage bois
l'utilisation de la biomasse et cetera
qui reste une des filières de
développement des énergies renouvelables
à laquelle je tiens tout
particulièrement et que je veux
absolument développer et notamment en
milieu rural sur la question du
Roundup en effet dans un premier temps
donc le Roundup la vente au particulier
est interdite en vente directe et doit
do être accompagné d'un conseil ça sera
effectif au 1er janvier et je me réjouis
de voir que non seulement la la le
réseau des jardinerie dans laquelle je
me suis
rendu à accepté dans dans dans un
partenariat positif de le mettre en
place avant même toute obligation et ça
c'est vraiment je pense une bonne
logique de progresser dans le domaine
écologique c'est-à-dire que les les
partenaires économiques d'eux-mêmes se
rendent compte bah qu'il y a des
solutions euh et deuxièmement suite à
cette action euh
les chaînes de distribution de grande
distributions qui nous disent que c'est
impossible viennent de me contacter pour
me dire qu'elles vont également mettre
en place carrefour pour ne pas le citer
ça c'est vraiment beaucoup de de de un
énorme tonnage de vente de de pesticides
mis en place de glyphosate et donc vous
voyez que les choses peuvent évoluer
très vite dès lors qu'on incite les
partenaires à rentrer dans des logiques
partenariales mais rassurez-vous ça ne
va pas diminuer le chiffre d'affaires
puisquils ont bien compris que il y
avait une montée en puissance aussi des
produits de substitution naturel à la
limite tant mieux euh et par conséquent
c'est vraiment la la la démonstration
qu'une évolution aussi de de l'industrie
des productions et des et des formes de
de vente et de service rendus au
consommateurs peuvent être efficaces dès
lors qu'on leur dit si toute façon si
vous ne le faites pas il y aura à un
moment une obligation donc vous avez
intérêt à ce que ça soit fait sur un
plan
volontariste avec un délai de
d'adaptation puisque de toute façon
c'est maintenant la règle alors faut-il
aller plus loin ma conviction c'est que
bien évidemment il faut aller plus loin
là je reviens d'Italie où il y a eu un
moratoire sur les néonicotinoïdes donc
alors qu'avant on me disait que c'était
interdit au niveau européen j'observe
que l'Italie a fait un moratoire sur les
néonicotinoïde et donc on aura ce débat
et dans la loi de transition énergétique
et dans la loi sur la biodiversité
puisque de toute façon ce moratoire a
déjà été voté il y a effectivement vous
le savez des grandes interrogations du
côté du monde agricole ce qui est
logique qui est respectable il faut voir
comment aussi est-ce qu'on fait évoluer
les pratiques agricoles avec quel
produit de substitution euh mais il est
bien évident que l'utilisation d'un
certain nombre de substances dans le
milieu agricole se retourne contre
l'agriculteur eux-même puisque en tuant
tous les tous les pollinisateurs en
particulier c'est l'agriculture
elle-même qui s'affaiblit donc je crois
que là aussi il y a des des une
évolution très forte des mentalités
parce que enfin euh les filières qui
sont dominantes sur la vente des
phytosanitaires commence à comprendre
que maintenant il y aura plus de retour
en arrière et qu'on va avancer aussi
avec des normes avec des règles et quand
on fait preuve effectivement
d'hésitation ou d'aller-retour à ce
moment-là les les les acteurs
économiques ne se mettent pas dans l'axe
il faut maintenant qu'il se mettent dans
l'axe parce que dans d'autres pays on
avance et on trouve des produits de
substitution qui correspondent non
seulement à l'intérêt de l'agriculture
mais aussi à l'intérêt
général merci Madame la Ministre alors
madame la ministre vous avez pas répondu
à ma question excusez-moi de interr
monsieur le Président sur le
diesel sur sur la sur l'interdiction du
diesel oui aujourd'hui il y a deux
choses c'est on est plus dans les
logiques d'interdiction du on peut pas
faire l'interdiction du diesel du jour
au lendemain regardez déjà la difficulté
du puisquon a encouragé pendant des
années et des années et des années
l'achat de véhicule diesel donc faut
aussi savoir raison garder être
pragmatique et et regarder la réalité de
la situation deuxièmement les
constructeurs font des efforts
considérables puisqueaujourd'hui il y a
des véhicules beaucoup moins polluants
des voitures diesel beaucoup moins
polluant je mais j'observe que la vous
devriez aller même beaucoup plus loin
sur votre question puisque on est à
quelques mois de la COP 21 on est sur la
problématique de l'utilisation des
énergies fossiles et la vraie question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on prépare
l'près pétrole c'est pas un problème de
guerre entre le diesel et l'essence
c'est comment est-ce qu'on prépare
l'après pétrole avec une mobilité
électrique ou autre une mobilité propre
qui n'utilise plus les énergies fossiles
la vraie question elle est là et ce qui
ce qui est trop ce qui est ce qu'il faut
vraiment accélérer c'est la mobilité
propre de la prépétrole sans énergie
fossile merci madame la ministre je vous
propose rassurez-vous tout le monde va
avoir la parole tout de suite si vous
êtes d'accord Mame le ministre parce que
chacun a demandé la parole je vais donc
il va me revenir une lourde
responsabilité c'est simplement de la
distribuer et je vous demande chers
collègues d'être le plus concis possible
pour nous offrir la possibilité d'avoir
le maximum de réponses madame toeville
s'il vous plaît merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous avez
abordé les problèmes que rencontre le
monde
agricole et je suis particulièrement
sensible étant sénatrice de scène
maritime où l'activité agricole est
encore importante je suis inquiète parce
que lorsque nous discutons avec les
exploitants agricoles moi j'ai
l'impression que euh ils ont encore
tendance à à minimiser les les
conséquences néfastes pour eux-mêmes euh
et c'est un petit peu inquiétant parce
que je je pense que non seulement la
pollution de l'air est grave mais les
exploitants agricoles ne voient pas
immédiatement les conséquences de la
pollution qui va les frapper et on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que à 20 ans à
30 ans des exploitants agricoles
commenent à souffrir de maladies euh qui
me semble-t-il ne sensibilise pas encore
suffisamment les jeunes exploitants
agricooles donc vous avez mentionné le
fait que des tables rondes sont en cours
pourriez-vous nous préciser les la forme
que prennent ces tables rondes comment
s'organise la réflexion avec les
Chambres d'agriculture et est-ce que des
échéances sont envisagées qui poseront
des incitations voire des obligations
aux exploitants agricolle je dirais
presque malgré eux je vous remercie
merci notre collègue Jacques
Chiron ministre euh je je me présente
donc je suis sénateur élu à grenobble
donc vous comprendrez que après vos
votre les informations que vous avez
donné on est on est particulièrement
sensible à Grenoble conerz la
configuration de cette ville une cuvette
qui est
particulièrement polluée duû au vent
dominant qui Rabat qui rabat la la
pollution sur le sur le sol euh nous
avons nous avons fait une
expérimentation avec de petits véhicules
électriques d'un constructeur une
soixantaine qui sont mis à disposition
dans le cadre d'une cycle d'autopartage
laadem d'ailleurs a apporté son aide de
120000 € en 2013 et c'est et c'est
particulièrement je dirais bénéfique par
contre c'est ces scopes c'estàd c'est
ces C
d'autopartage ne pourrait-elle pas
bénéficier au niveau de la prime
de la prime plus c'estàd les 10000 €
aujourd'hui elle bénéficie d'une prime
normale comme à n'importe quelle
entreprise de 6000 6800 € je crois
quelque chose comme çaon et est-ce queà
partir du moment où c'est une scope dans
le cadre de l'autopartage c'està-dire en
direction des particuliers on ne
pourrait pas faire bénéficier ces ces
scopes d'une prime supérieure comme
puisquelle s'adresse plutôt au
particulierers et
donc pourrait bénéficier d'une prime
supplémentaire sachant que il faut il
faut inciter nos nos nos notre nos
concitoyens aller de plus en plus vers
ce Ste ce système de déplacement et de
et de location de véhicule merci merci
chers collègues Louis
Nère madame la ministre le diagnostic
est
partagé on a non seulement un
contentieux européen donc qui est
reconnu
par Bruxelles de la situation qui est la
nôtre en France mais je rappellerai que
nous avons 40000 morts prématuré et
40000 morts prématuré en France c'est
beaucoup et ce sont notamment les plus
jeunes et les plus âgés qui souffrent de
cette pollution alors quand vous avez
annoncé tout à l'heure qu'il y avait une
amélioration en 2014 je vois que vous
êtes une ministre optimiste en fait ce
qui s'est passé en 2014 c'est que nous
avons eu des conditions climatiques
météorologique favorable et du coup ça a
baissé maintenant sur le fond je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il y ait une baisse totale
par ailleurs au niveau du Sénat avec la
commission du développement durable nous
avons créé une commission sur le diesel
pour se rendre compte pour savoir ce
qu'il en était réellement et
effectivement on découvre un certain
nombre de choses et notamment des
sources de pollution qu'on avait
tendance à oublier nous travaillons dans
ce domaine-là et je pense qu'on aura une
position équ équilibré en fonction de ce
que nous venons d'apprendre mais vous
avez là encore raison c'est
l'prèspétrole c'est le l'énergie fossile
qu'il va falloir diminuer alors le
projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique pour l'aide financière pour
les véhicules électriques nous ne
pouvons qu'être favorable après le Livre
vert et sur l'indemnité kilométrique
vélo en tant que rapporteur je me suis
battu pour que ce soit inscrit et je
vous dirai madame la ministre qu'il faut
se préparer aussi dans un deuxème temps
mais ça arrive déjà au Japon aujourd'hui
à
l'hydrogène le cadre législatif pour les
bus vous avez là-dessus évolué madame la
ministre et j'en suis très heureux dans
la mesure où vous avez désormais un
classement de très faible émission et de
faible émission ce qui me paraît être
justifiée et la mesure convient
effectivement à l'ensemble des autorités
de transport après cette modification
alors j'ai deux questions une question
sur la santé nous n'avez vous n'avez pas
abordé la pollution intérieure alors
qu'elle elle est souvent supérieure à la
pollution extérieure et pour avoir été
rapporteur du Grenel 2 de
l'environnement j'avais déjà cette
impression là la deuxème problème sur la
santé vous n'avez pas non plus aborder
les particules fines ces particules
fines
pour lequel j'ai demandé en tant que
rapporteur qu'elle soit désormais
contrôlée dans la loi de transition
énergétique parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
là encore elle joue un rôle négatif
c'est un élément pollueur majeur là
aussi avec des sources très diversifiées
d'ailleurs et puis la deuxième question
portera sur le niveau financier vous
nous avez dit les cota que n'a pas été
supprimé j'en prends bonne note mais
est-ce que vous arriverez est-ce que
vous pouvez vous engager sur la pérenit
de cette écotaxe et à quel niveau à quel
niveau sachant qu'il nous faudrait
1illard millions au niveau de la fite si
nous voulons continuer à assurer les
financements des infrastructures et
enfin sur les transport public il y a
une mesure
contradictoire vous avez augmenté le
gouvernement propose d'augmenter les
seuils sociaux de 9 à 11 c'est très bien
mesure formidable sauf que ça impacte
directement le versement de transport et
cela signifie un transfert financier en
centaines de millions d'euros au G nous
avons fait ces évaluations là sur les
collectivités sur les autorités de
transport alors que l'on change les
seuils d'accord mais que l'on transfère
pas une nouvelle charge sur les
collectivités merci nous poursuivons ma
collègueel Didier merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre auront
l'occasion effectivement dans le débat
de la loi transition énergétique de de
revenir sur un certain nombre de sujets
euh et et et les mesures qui sont dans
ce texte vont concourir à améliorer les
choses j'ai trois questions premièrement
euh le rapport de lanes on en parle
beaucoup avez-vous une idée de quand il
va pouvoir sortir parce que nous
attendons ces travaux avec impatience
dans plusieurs domaines la deuxième
question est-ce que l'on
considère que les transports
ferroviaires sont une solution dans les
transports vous on a cité les véhicules
électrique bien entendu on est dans on
imagine qu'on va vers le l'aprèspétrole
et donc est-ce qu'on considère que la
solution pour le transport en
particulier collectif c'est par exemple
le transport ferroviaire et quels sont
qu'est-ce que ça ça veut dire ensuite
pour les mesures à prendre troisième
chose euh on sait bien qu'on va pas
pouvoir tout régler le même jour mais
lorsque des mesures sont prévues dans
une loi par exemple ou dans dans dans
des circulaires ce qui est important
c'est qu'elle soit suivie des faits
est-ce que vous avez une idée de la
manière dont vous allez pouvoir suivre
de près les mesures qui sont prévues
dans la loi prévues dans les circulaires
de telle sorte que on s'assure de
l'effectivité du du du travail réalisé
et dernière question la qualité de l'air
on l'a vu dans dans cette mission elle
touche tous les citoyens mais elle
touche également les citoyens les
travailleurs dans le monde du travail il
y a aujourd'hui des seuils différents
d'acceptabilité pour le citoyen
ordinaire et pour le monde du travail
qu'en est-il de la réflexion sur ce
sujet je vous remercie merci ma cher
collègue Martial Bourquin
oui madame la ministre euh j'aais
j'aurais tout d'abord remarquer que
votre position concernant le rondop est
une position courageuse comme vous
l'avez prise il y a quelques temps sur
le bisphenol A c'est important euh parce
que les lobby sont important aussi en
face de vous et vous osez euh prendre
des positions comme cellees-ci il faut
le remarquer il faut le saluer euh et je
dois vous dire que pour les particuliers
c'est un premier pas
il faudra qu'ensuite on aborde la
question des professionnels parce que ça
va avec
euh je le glyphosate maintenant a été
reconnu comme cancérigène par
l'OMS on sait très bien qu'on fonctionne
avec l'Europe sur ces questions et euh
comment il faudra un jour se
passer de ces produits qui sont non
seulement nfastes pour la santé pour nos
sols pour nos écosystèmes
et franchement faut le faire ce que vous
avez fait d'une certaine façon moi je le
salue est-ce que Madame la Ministre on
pourrait retravailler sur les aides
européennes concernant
l'agriculture on sait qu'elles sont
importantes pour redéployer autrement
une agriculture plus
soutenable aujourd'hui vu la concurrence
vu la concurrence entre pays
européens il est important que les a
européenne puisse permettre un
développement beaucoup plus soutenable
et que certains produits au niveau de
l'Europe
soi
comment directement directement proscrit
directement proscrit voilà je pense que
sur les alternatifes aura plancher aussi
parce que supprimer un herbicide puis ne
pas le remplacer pour les professionnels
ça pose un problème il faudrait
travailler aussi sur les les
comment le les les les alternatives je
vous avais aussi interrogé sur la
question des traitements des grumes à
ciel
ouvert c'est la filière bois qui le fait
c'est ces produits sont hautement
toxiques il y a eu des des essais de
l'Universit tranche compé avec des sures
qui provenaient de ces
traitements ça détruit complètement les
écosystèmes et on continue à ciel ouvert
pour l'air et pour les sols de est-ce
que il il ne faut pas des interdictions
et faire en sorte que ces traitements là
soient réservés en en vasclos c'estàdire
réservés dans des dans des entreprises
qui seraient équipé comme les cabines de
peinture dernière chose madame la
ministre sur le
diesel j'étais à une réunion il y a peu
de temps on me disait que le
diesel Euro 6 l'énorme EUR 6 était moins
polluant que
l'essence est-ce que nous pourrions
avoir voir sur ces questions un méta
point de
vue des analyses parce que vous savez
très bien quand on met le diesel puis
qu'on parle de tous les diesels ceux qui
n'ont pas de filtre à particulle sont
extrêmement polluants ceux qui ont un
filtre à particules sont beaucoup moins
polluants mais la norme R6 on nous dit
que et surtout les nouveaux moteurs que
toutes les marques s'apprête à sortir
dans dans en 17 et en 18 2017 2018 on
dit qu'ils seront beaucoup moins
polluants que les moteurs essence est-ce
que sur ces questions vous pouvez nous
éclairer merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue Fabiane Keller s'il vous plaît
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président de
me passer la parole les sujets
commencent à converger on retrouve
certains thèmes à mon tour madame la
ministre je voudrais vous remercier
d'être là mais vous interrogez sur la
suppression de l'échotaxe à la suite de
la madame le rapporteur leilla haichi et
et Louis ngre c'était une ressource
importante pour la fite pour organiser
le transfert du mode de transport
individuel vers notamment le le
ferroviaire c'est une recette qui est
perdue nous le vivons d'autant plus mal
moi je suis frontalière de l'Allemagne
et on voit bien le l'effet de la MTH
allemande de d'apaisement et de
d'encouragement à
d'autres modes de de transport des des
marchandises est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des pistes sur les autres
financements que vous envisagez de
mettre en œuvre on veut réaliser la
transition énergétique de manière
concrète il faudra des ressources
financières vous avez un dispositif de
d'encouragement pour les véhicules
électriques si on veut élargir ce
dispositif comme le président martial
Sadier l'évoqué à l'instant c'est un
levier efficace pour l'amélioration de
la qualité de l'air il faut une
ressource financière avez-vous des
pistes à ce sujet euh deè question la
loi Macron que nous sommes en train
d'examiner en commission spéciale euh
ouvre la voie à des lignes de bus
nombreuses qui d'ailleurs sont déjà
annoncées sur les sites Internet des
autocaristes
euh faisant craindre un transfert assez
massif du train vers le bus vous avez
annoncé qu'il y aurait des normes
particulières pour ces bus mais comment
seront-elles appliquées est-ce que dans
tous les cas on ne peut pas craindre he
puisque le
bilan pour la pollution de l'air du
train est bien meilleure puisque
l'essentiel des trains sont quand même
électriques que ceux du bus
quel impact de ce transfert annoncé pour
la pollution de lait trisème sujet un
peu vaste j'ai eu le plaisir de faire un
rapport sur le véhicule écologique avec
Denis Baupin là aussi si le véhicule
électrique est d'une des pistes il y en
a d'autres notamment la réduction du
poids du véhicule le paradoxe du
véhicule électrique étant le poids des
des batterie qui voilà qui mécaniquement
à moteur constant génère un besoin
énergétique supérieur euh j'adore le
vélo j'adore le vélo électrique qui est
une formule intéressante mais quel
dispositif d'encouragement pour des
véhicules intermédiaires un peu plus
protecteur mais qui peuvent représenter
de vrais leviers sur la baisse du poids
en améliorant également la
motorisation une baisse très
significative de leur contribution à la
pollution de l'air enfin dernier point
et pardon le 4e j'ai eu le bonheur de
réaliser à la commission des finances
des études successives sur les
contentieux européens
en matière de la pollution de l'air
malheureusement tout ça est très
inertiel comme vous l'avez rappelé
madame la ministre ça met du temps pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air on a vu
lors de la l'audition précédente que les
PPA sont en train de d'être prescrit ou
où ils sont assez récents quel risque là
aussi
financier d'un contentieux dès lors que
sur les PM10 nous avons déjà la vie
motivé je rappelle que la la commission
a donné il y a quelques années des
règles de calcul hein sur les sur le
coût des contentieux qui aboutirai à une
condamnation de la France je vous
remercie merci mes cher collèguees
François grodidier
oui donc François grodidier sénateur UMP
de de laamiselle et malgré mon
importance politique je tiens à dire que
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'on dit mes prédécesseurs et même le
sénateur Bourquin sur euh même les
félicitations qu'il a pu vous adresser
sur votre indépendance vis-à-vis
compris de de l'industrie chimique sur
le bisphénol A ou sur le le Roundup euh
serait peut-être plus critique pour
revenir sur le sujet étant demoiselle
sur les cotax poiss lourd parce que le
dirais que d'abord pour prendre le
problème de façon plus globale si nos
concitoyens ont souvent un problème avec
l'écologie c'est que d'une part d'abord
c'est un problè la fois de clarté de
responsabilité de clarté ça doit être la
clarté sur les messages alors certains
messages sont assez flous surtout
lorsqu'on est pas dans la certitude hein
qu'on met en œuvre le principe de
précaution parfois plus que celui de
prévention et et notamment sur des
sujets comme les les les pesticides sur
tout ce qui nous intéresse où les effets
sont à long terme produ des maladies aux
causes multifactorielles quoi c'est
difficile de de par avec des certitudes
absolues même si aujourd'hui on est de
plus en plus conforté sur
l'établissement de de de certaines
vérités dérangeante mais euh sur les les
responsabilités on voit bien qu'à chaque
fois par exemple qu'on prend une mesure
limitative de la circulation routière on
aura le défenseur des automobilistes qui
vont expliquer le rôle très marginal
automobile par rapport aux source
d'émission de de de particulle et euh
que on a trop tendance dans le flou des
responsabilités à chercher à évacuer
pour chacun sa
responsabilité pour celle de l'autre
donc si on veut que que toutes les
responsabilités collectives soi assumé
avec précision il faut être précis sur
la responsabilité de chacun alors par
exemple sur le problème du diisel et de
l'essence on a un problème le discours
est pas net c'est effectivement dire
avec précision sur est-ce que la
nouvelle norme eur6 est non polluante et
est-ce on sait plus si c'est en ville
qu'on doit proscrire le diesel et pas
sur les long tragés est-ce que sur long
traget est-ce qu'il vaut pas mieux du
diesel qui est moins de CO2 et avec des
pot catalytiques qui sont bien chauds et
qui marchent bien le train quand on peut
peut pas tout le temps surtout quand on
supprime certains trains bon
donc où est-ce qu'en ville il faut
absolument encourager uniquement
l'essence ou
l'hybride quoi électrique essence mais
mais là on n'est pas sur des vérités
établies euh alors on a les
constructeurs nationaux qui aujourd'hui
c'est tant mieux ont tendance à
remplacer le petit diesel par de de de
l'essence mais pour l'instant le le
discours public est flou est-ce qu'on
doit aller sur la fin du alors bien sûr
le mieux sera l'électrique mais en
attendant quelle est la décision
responsable c'est pas clair alors sur
ensuite le principe du polluur payeur je
crois que nos concitoyens sont acquis
mais c'est pas ce qui est mise en œuvre
alors on peut évoquer qui est des
pollutions agricoles ou industrielles
mais sur le transport vous me dites
l'écotax poiss lourd finalement n'est
pas Bolier elle est remplacée par une
taxe de 2 centimes sur le diesel quoi je
suis élu de laamoiselle je sais que les
poids lourds font le plein au Luxembourg
ils ont pas la taxe ets vont descendre
jusqu'en Espagne avec le carburant prise
en poids lourd et et et nos concitoyens
ont un immense sentiment d'injustice
quand eux vont payer les 2 centimes de
plus sur le diesel euh que les petits
artises quoi ou ou que les petites
entreprises payent le versement
transport qu'on envisage même des
autoroutes de dessertes qui serent pour
des trajets pendulaires on envisage
aujourd'hui le page par exemple sur la
31 dans cette même région alors même que
le transit international y échappe et je
crois aussi que euh euh on on serait
beaucoup plus efficace en pédagogie on
renforcerait l'acceptabilité si on
donnait vraiment le sentiment qu'on est
dans la mise en œuvere du principe du
polur payeur j'aurais j'aurais eu
d'autres points mais je vais me faire
disputer par le rapporteur donc je
m'arrête là
non par le président qui n'est pas là
pour disputer qui est là vous l'avez
compris pour distribuer la parole et
vous posez deux très courtes questions
madame la ministre puisque je me plie
bien volontiers à la concision où en
est-on aujourd'hui de l'élaboration du
plan de réduction des émulitions de
polluant atmosphérique qui était prévu
pour la fin de l'année avec une
évaluation à mi 2015 deuxème question
comment le ministère dont vous avez la
charge perçoit-t-il et surtout
envisage-t-il l'évolution du financement
des associations agréées de surveillance
de la qualité de l'air vous avez bien
compris que leur financement est loin
d'être assuré qu'il décroit plutôt
actuellement madame la ministre je vous
remercie si on pouvait avoir dans un
petit quart d'heure l'ensemble de vos
réponses à la fois pour respecter votre
temps et puis également parce que vous
avez des collègues à vous du
gouvernement qui sont je dirais dans les
starting
bloc je vais essayer de d'accomplir des
prouesses donc euh madame la sénatrice
Toqueville euh vous avez souligné
effectivement le fait que les pollutions
agricoles frappent d'abord les
agriculteurs et c'est vrai et d'ailleurs
on le sait depuis longtemps ça a été
longtemps tabou euh mais pour les élus
ruraux dont dont j'ai été en tant que
députés des Deux Sèvres on savait parce
qu'on voyait les statistiques de la
mutualité sociale agricole et on savait
déjà euh le taux de de cancer beaucoup
plus élevé pour les agriculteurs
beaucoup plus élevés pour les
viticulteurs on sait aujour aujourd'hui
et heureusement que ces informations
maintenant sont sont mis sur la table
notamment les problèmes de cancer il y a
eu un rapport récent sur les
malformations génitales des bébés dans
les dans les zones où il y a eu beaucoup
d'utilisation de de pesticides on voit
dans certaines régions de France aussi
l'âge de la puberté qui s'est
dramatiquement qui dramatiquement
diminué certaines petites filles de 8
ans ont déjà sont déjà l'âge de la
puberté et on sait maintenant que c'est
dû aux produits phytosanitair il est
évident comme ça a été dit par plusieurs
d'entre vous qu'il faut vraiment
maintenant accélérer la transition
agricole vers l'agriculture verte et en
particulier dans la viticulture et
évident qu'un jour d'ailleurs tous les
vigobbles seront bio on le voit
maintenant même les grands crus se
disent évoluent vers le bio et on se
dira même et comment ça a pu durer aussi
longtemps que des viticulteurs eux-mêmes
sininoculent finalement des maladies
extrêmement graves j'étais l'autre jour
dans une ville bio et ça m'a fait ça m'a
vraiment touché parce que l'agricultur
bio disait le viticulteur bio disait
enfin mes enfants peuvent jouer dans la
vigne donc ils savent en plus ce qu'ils
subissent très directement par un
système d'intermédiaire qui voilà qui
s'enrichit aussi sur sur ce type de
pratique Monsieur Jacques Chinon euh sur
les alors vous demandez si les 10000 €
peuvent être attribués aux entreprises
d'autopartage alors la réponse
malheureusement n'est pas positif
pourquoi parce que en contrepartie de
ces 10000 € il y a l'obligation de
mettre à la casse un vieux véhicule
diesel donc voyez c'est pour éliminer un
vieux véhicule mais bon on peut regarder
comment est-ce qu'on peut avantager
compris fiscalement pourquoi pas
faudrait faudrait regarder ce que l'on
peut faire pour encourager les sociétés
d'autopartage Louis vous avez posé
la question des pollutions intérieur
c'est un sujet que vous connaissez bien
effectivement c'est qui était vous en
êtes occupé de activement dans le dans
le Grenel de de l'environnement donc
c'est un sujet qu'il faut absolument pas
laisser de côté je l' évoqué tout à
l'heure notamment avec les les problèmes
de revêtement de sol les problèmes de
peinture les problèmes de d'utilisation
des produits de nettoyage qui
contiennent des néonicotinoïdes et
cetera et donc il y a un guide pratique
que j'ai fait faire par le ministère sur
euh le choix des des des des revêtements
le choix des produits d'entretien pour
que effectivement euh on ne puisse pas
se polluer mais sans même le savoir donc
ça c'est très important que les services
municipaux en particulier que tous les
gestionnaires euh des lieux d'accueil du
public soient informés euh de ces soit
informés de ces choix qui s'offrent à
eux pour diminuer la pollution
intérieure les particules fines ça c'est
un sujet aussi très important qui doit
faire l'objet d'une mesure en tant que
telle les ressources de la fite bah les
2 centimes seront sont maintenu bien
évidemment il y a pas de sentiments plus
hein pour l'instant mais ils sont ils
sont là donc il continuent à alimenter
la fite et sur la question des seuils
sociaux qu'on avait sur laquelle on
avait l'occasion de de de d'évoquer
effectivement c'était une observation
très judicieuse que j'ai transmis
immédiatement au ministre compétent qui
est chargé de suivre le ce projet de loi
sur les seuils sociaux pour que il
puisse y avoir une réponse très précise
à la question que vous soulevez euh
Eveline Didier le rapport de l'anè Ben
nous l'aurons je pense au début d'année
prochaine donc on pourra vous le
communiquer également rapidement les
transports ferroviaires bien évidemment
les transports ferroviaires font partie
des transports propres j'ajoute que on
aimerait bien voir aussi se développer
les transport du fret ferroviaire parce
que c'est quand même aussi l'alternative
au camion comment suivre les mesures
prévu je pense qu'on pourra les suivre
dans le cadre du Conseil national de la
transition écologique où à la fois parce
que je je vais essayer de faire en sorte
qu'au moment de la promulgation de la
loi sur la transition énergétique avec
le volet transport propre les textes
d'application soit prêt au moment de la
promulgation donc c'est un travail
considérable dans lequel j'ai engagé les
services de mon min ministère et en même
temps pour nous pourrons voir avec le
Conseil national de la transition
écologique comment assurer le suivi des
actions à la fois réglementa et des
projets et des appels à projets qui vont
avec Monsieur Martial Bourquin merci
pour vos vos encouragements sur
l'élimination du Roundup c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile hein parce que on se
heurte quand même à des à des lobbyes
très importants il est évident qu'après
il faut les éliminer partout mais je
pense que nous avons un rôle pédagogique
parce que vous comprenez Si on commence
par les parties particulier là où j'ai
légalement la possibilité d'agir et que
je le fais qu'en même temps les communes
s'engagent dans l'appel à projet du
ministère sur territoire terre sainees
zéro pesticides et je vois la montée en
puissance des communes qui éliminent ça
y les pesticides dans les jardins
publics j'ai lancé en tant que ministre
de tutelle des transports aussi
l'élimination des pesticides sur tous
les bords de route national avec des
pratiques de fauche tardives pour et et
figurez-vous que les bordures de route
nationales la totalité de ces bordures
c'est l'équivalent de la totalité de
surface des parcs nationaux donc vous
voyez des mesures qui paraissent
accessoires deviennent centrales dès
lors qu'elles sont massives et qu'elles
s'appuient sur sur l'ensemble du
territoire national retravailler sur les
aides européennes évident et d'ailleurs
j'observe que au niveau européen les
ministres de l'Environnement poussent de
plus en plus pour qu'il a des mutations
très fortes vers
l'agriculture verte et enfin sur la
question des du traitement des grumes il
y a d'autres problème comme ça de
traitement effectivement soit
paraagricole soit industriel en plein
air c'est ce sont des produits hautement
toxique et c'est vrai que dans les plans
locaux de de de diminution de la
pollution il ne faut pas oublier ces
sujets là et c'est vrai que suite à
votre interpellation ce sont des thèmes
que la direction de la prévention des
risques du ministère va intégrer à ces
appels d'offre support et à ses
instructions sur le diesel alors est-ce
que c'est le r 6 c'est moins polluant ou
pas alors soyons bien clair ce n'est pas
moins polluant il y a moins de CO2 c'est
vrai mais il y a plus de particules et
plus d'oxyde d'azote donc il faut donner
acte quand même au aux industriels du
diesel des efforts qu'ils font parce
qu'il y a moins de CO2 effectivement
mais il y a encore plus de particules et
plus d'oxyde d'azote que que pour
l'essence mais comme je le disais
globalement n'pposons pas le diesel à
l'essence ce qu'il faut c'est c'est
passer au-delà et et préparer le
l'aprèspétrole Madame Fabienne Keller
vous avez évoqué l'écotax avec votre
collègue François
grodidier
effectivement je rappelle he que
lescotax cétait 25 % minimum de coût de
fonctionnement j'estime que quand un
état prélève l'impôt c'est la totalité
qui doit être restitué aux actions donc
je vais pas revenir sur les défauts du
système tel qu'il avait été imaginé de
l'usine à gaz en jeu de mot tel qu'il
avait été imaginé sans parler des
problèmes de des meutes en Bretagne
c'est enfin dans des territoires qui
n'étaient pas les territoires traversés
considérés comme territoires de transit
pour les poils lours du nord au sud de
l'Europe alors il y a une solution c'est
la mise au disposition de ces portiques
aux régions et aux départements
concernés la région et-de-fance a déjà
fait cette demande donc les portiques
installés en région î-de-fance seront
mis à disposition des régions ou des
département traversé qui le souhaite et
c'est vrai que la région-de-fance ou les
régions côtières teles que la Vau
modisel
Alsace sont directement impactés par des
dispositifs allemands payants et donc
des détournements de de trafic mais
l'avantage ce sera que ces régions
pourront prélever directement au passage
sous le portique les taxes qui vont avec
le passage des camions et par renvoyer
un système de de de satellite qui
renvoyait vers un système d'ordinateur à
mes lui-même renvoyé vers je ne sais
quoi ensuite des factures qui arrivaient
au DOM ici des des opérateurs qui
entre-temps auraient pu se délocaliser
ailleurs ensuite retrouver les adresses
envoyer les factures à postérieur enfin
un système à mon avis qui était
absolument ingérable et qui en plus
entraîit le blocage du pays parce que
les compagnie de transport ne comprenent
pas qu'au passage il y ait 25 % de
prélèvement de ce qu'ils allaient payer
en coût de fonctionnement de ce
dispositif donc dans un premier temps il
y a les 2 centimes qui vont la fite et
dans un second temps les régions les
départements qui veulent bénéficier des
portiques avec des systèmes
technologiques beaucoup plus simples et
manuels comme sur les autoroutes les
camions passent et et les régions et les
départements prélèvent le paiement le
péage qui sera
entièrement restitué aux départements et
régions qui auront fait le choix de
garder ces portiques et d'en définir
l'usage et les
tarifs sur la loi Macron et ben
effectivement vous avez complètement
raison il faudrait que les bus qui
circule j'ai appelé d'ailleurs son
attention soit des bus propres et ça
permettra aussi de faire un marché
solevable pour faciliter le la mise au
point et la vente des des transports
collectifs
propres vous aviez fait un rapport avec
deny bein quel dispositif
d'encouragement me me demandez-vous je
crois que on s'en est inspiré d'ailleurs
de ce rapport don je vous félicite avec
Denis Baupin notamment pour le volet
transport propre de la transition
énergétique et pour le
pour l'électrique ben oui il y a le
déploiement des Bordes électriques mais
ça aussi ça relève finalement des des
agglomérations et dans le cadre de
l'appel à projet que j'aiévoqué tout à
l'heure il va appartenir aux villes aidé
par le le ministère de mettre en place
des transports électriques performants
et de réinventer les déplacements
urbains je pense que c'est vraiment la
civilisation de la ville là qui est en
jeu et que vraiment il y a il y AP des
solutions de l'imagination de la
mobilisation des citoyens du covoiturage
et cetera François grodidier donc j'ai
répondu sur
l'écotax et sur le diesel également je
pense avoir répondu aux interrogations
voilà monsieur le Président vous avez
conclu par donc une question sur le plan
de réduction des émissions de de
polluant qui constitue donc la stratégie
nationale et le programme d'action en
faveur de la qualité de l'air pour la
période 2016-2020 donc c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet très important les
réflexions sont engagées donc depuis la
fin de de l'année dernière les comités
de pilotage s réuni plusieurs fois comme
je dit tout à l'heure il y a un point
d'État que je vous pourrais vous
communiquer qui a été présenté au
Conseil national de l'air que j'ai réuni
le 2 juin et aujourd'hui nous avons des
réunions sectorielles qui
seront dont il sera rendu compte d'abord
avant le 32 au moment début juillet euh
et début non 30 juin 2016 pour la
finalisation mais euh d'ici là il y a
quatre group groupes de travail qui sont
mis en place comment offrir des
avantages aux utilisateurs des véhicules
moins polluants grâce au certificat de
la qualité de l'air comment encourager
les élus locaux à s'engager euh à
travers les appels à projet même au-delà
quel cadre péren peut-on donner à la
lutte contre la pollution grâce aux
mesures du projet de loi de transition
énergétique euh et donc je pense que
nous pourrons faire converger l'ensemble
de ces préoccupations pour à la fois euh
donner quelles sont les nouvelles normes
euh le contenu des appels à projet mais
aussi les accompagnements financiers qui
vont avec mais suite à votre question je
vais essayer de de bien repréciser les
les données le calendrier et les
échéances pour pouvoir également vous le
communiquer sur le financement des
associations actuellement il y a les
crédits budgétaires de l'État 17
millions d'euros par an c'est quand même
pas rien les subventions versées par les
collectivités 14 millions d'euros par an
les les dons effectués par les
industriels qui donnent enfin les dons
qui donnent droit à déduction du montant
de la taxe générale sur les activités
polluantes auquel ils sont assujétis
dans la limite de 171000 € par site ou
de 25 % du montant de la TG PDU c'est
l'équivalent de 15 à 20 millions d'euros
qui sont ainsi reversés le budget de
fonctionnement annuel des associations
est de 45 à 50 millions
d'euros et bien évidemment tout cela est
rediscuté lors de chaque vote du budget
donc surqu je je compte sur votre
soutien mais ce qui veut dire aussi
qu'en contrepartie je pense qu'on est
aussi en mesure de demander à ces
associations aussi des contte-rendus de
leurs actions
euh un suivi de leur efficacité une
évaluation de leur travaux des
conventions qui qui peuvent être
également contrôlé et qu'on puisse
contrôler clairement l'utilisation de
ces fonds pour que vraiment ils soi
aussi opérationnel et utile pour obtenir
les les résultats que nous recherchons
tous merci madame la ministre c'est le
cas je vais proposer une juste 30
secondes à Madame la rapporteur parce
que vraiment il faut que je suis gardien
du temps Madame la Ministre simplement
pour revenir sur le sujet du du diesel
ça fait plus de 32 ans qu'on sait que le
diesel est est cancérigène nous sommes
dans un pays qui a supprimé plus de
100000 emplois dans l'automobile nous
avons dans le cadre de la COP 21 dans le
département supprimé en moins de 2 ans
3000 emplois nous allons devoir dans le
cadre justement précisément de la cop21
un un porter plus de des diel
électriques nous revenons nous avons
fait une nous sommes déplacés dans la
région enfin dans dans le Nord nous
avons auditionné Renault et Toyota
précisément ces derniers considèrent que
justement on ne va pas assez loin dans
dans les normes que les technologies
avancent pour reprendre ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure vous dites à juste
titre qu'il faut assurer la transition
aux énergies fossile pour autant laadem
en 2013 a financé à hauteur de 110
millions d'euros euh les moteurs
hybrides et essence et di ail alors même
que nous avons des technologies type
hydrogène électrique est-ce qu'il y a
pas une forme de de d'incohérence
puisque comme je le disais dans mon
préembule ça fait plus de 32 ans qu'on
sait que le dzel est cancérigène est-ce
qu'on est pas plutôt dans une impasse
dans une impasse économique les emplois
de demain sont les emplois liés au
développement durable aux technologies
nouvelles et le diesel appartient à un
temps à un temps passé est-ce que il y a
pas une forme justement de résistance ou
de de facilité à céder sur disons les
choses hein le lobby le lobby du diesel
puisque il existe des technologies qu'
faire les échanges que nous avons eu
avec Toyota et et Renault qui explicite
que justement nous n'allons pas assez
loin merci Madame la Ministre
alors n'a pas été versé finalement donc
là je crois que les choses sont
cohérentes deuxièmement il faut savoir
ce que l'on veut soit on dit
effectivement qu'il y a 40000 morts
prématuré à cause de la pollution mais à
ce moment-là on prend des mesures
beaucoup plus radicales comprisv vous
êtes élu de Paris mais pourquoi il y a
encore du diesel dans Paris voyez il y a
aussi un pardon mais il y a aussi une
contradiction entre les discours et les
actes quand j'ai dit récemment comment
se fait-il qu'il a encore des
bus comment comment se fait-il qu' de la
région parisienne comment se fait-il
qu'il a des bus diesel dans Paris des
taxis diesel dans Paris et que on nous
dise mais y a 20 mines à 40000 morts
prématurés mais alors on arrête tout de
suite et on dit ben voilà et non
maintenant les les taxis seront les bus
seront électriques pourquoi c'est Silan
donc on est tous comptable de ce qui est
fait vous voyez donc moi je veux bien
qu'on qu'on a une idéologie anti
diéselle et c'est vrai qu'il y a des
pollutions mais en même temps à ce
moment-là il faut passer à l'action donc
il y a une contradiction entre le vous
voyez le côté dramatique de constat et
la faiblesse des actions qui vont avec
et quand je dis mais enfin comment
voulez-vous que les gens comprennent
qu'on leur dit à eux vous allez avoir un
Calico pour dire votre voiture est
polluante et ils sortent dans la rue et
ils voient des des des des des fumées
noires qui s'échappent des des taxis et
des transports collectifs c'est c'est
incompréhensible donc je pense que je
pense que à un moment voilà il faut que
la société prenne en effet des décision
radicale pour comme pour reprendre
pardon mais mais je crois qu'on est dans
un contexte où justement le pape
François vient de faire une encyclique
qui est exceptionnelle qui est juste
exceptionnelle qui appelle à une
révolution écologique qui appelle à
écologie radicale et bien dans ces
domaines là soyons et ayons en effet une
écologie radicale et à un moment fixons
des échéances en prenant en compte aussi
de l'implication c'est-à-dire des
ENCI madame la minist merci pour votre
disponibilité d'autant qu'au Sénat on
sait que être radical c'est ça plusieurs
acceptions
voilà voilà pour l'audition de segolan
royale la ministre de l'écologie qui
avait été auditionnée par les sénateurs
de la commission d'enquête sur le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air vous le savez depuis cette
commission d'enquête a rendu ses
conclusions et elle a estimé à 100
milliards d'euros par an le coût annuel
pour la France de cette pollution de
l'air depuis d'ailleurs Segolen royale a
fait de nombreuses annonces au mois de
juillet pour prendre en compte ce
problème vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site publicsenat.fr très bonne journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires